hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2022 vhs olympiad currently
being played in chennai uh it is around
aksadvani versus libya dietary spirano
it is the first match or rather the
first game of the match that we'll be
covering it is india 2 versus germany
and uh we're gonna cover some games and
then we're gonna discuss who is winning
what in the olympia because anything is
still possible germany is facing india
too armenia is facing spain uh
uzbekistan is facing netherlands there's
a great clash between abu satram and
anishigiri also the main team of india
is facing the united states uh so you
know
it's pretty crazy in the final round but
like i said let's cover a few games and
then we're going to discuss what what's
happening so it's around aksadvani
versus libya dieter nicipiano a
gentleman i consider to be one of the
modern
masters of the mystic hearts if you
remember his game against hikaru
nakamura in 2019 fiji grand swiss
it's just a phenomenal game if you want
to watch that game before this one to
kind of get in the mood i will put a
link to it in the description below it
features a spectacular queen sacrifice
and he just completely shatters um
hikaru nakamura i mean it was a
spectacular game
but let's uh now focus on this one uh uh
as it's also a really brilliant game uh
so around salvani opens with uh ponte e4
we have c6 uh uh nisban who goes for the
karo khan defense with d d4d5 and now
pawn to e5 going for the advanced
variation of the karo khan the ship to
f5 and now knight to f3 we have pawn to
e6 this is the standard setup the bishop
is out of the cage and now bishop to e2
and now pawn to c5 seemingly wasting the
tempo but that's the whole point we want
to attack white center and free up the
square for the black knight so bishop to
e3 and now not going knight to c6 but
knight to d7 instead
we have castles and now we have knight
to e7 uh pawn to c4 attacking the the
pawn on d5 and now d captures on c4
bishop captures on c4 and a6 preparing
b5 uh this has all been played before so
nothing new here there's a whole lot of
theory just developing pieces knight to
c6 now and pawn to d5 uh now attacking
the knight here uh and here we have
knight c captures on e5 and up until
this point it's all been pretty standard
stuff white always captures an e5 here
and there are a handful of games where
this exact same position occurred
however here salvani prepared something
special he plays bishop back to e2 and
it is now already as of move 12 that we
have a completely new game so it's a
fancy pawn sacrifice and uh black will
have to play a set of very very precise
moves in order to survive this so here
knight captures on f3's played bishop
captures and now just knight to e5
putting pressure on the bishop here we
have bishop to f4 now attacking the
knight and if you capture on f3 it's not
all that great you still can't do
anything about this pawn because then
you weaken your your bishop on f5 and
you still have to play two more moves
with black to castle the king to safety
so instead we have knight to d3
uh which is uh attacking the bishop on
f4 also putting pressure on the pawn on
b2 but here uh raunak just plays e
captures uh d captures on e6
uh which is kind of i believe the move
that uh uh celebrated uh uh
an hispano's game against hikaru
nakamura i could be wrong i you know
it's i think it could be the captures on
e6 i'm not sure i could check in order
you know not to trick you guys uh let me
just check real quickly uh yeah it's uh
e captures on e6 sorry not the d
captures on e6 it was e captures on f6
uh the the move from the nisi piano uh
hikaru game but uh yeah also uh nicely
done very very symbolic so f captures on
e6 and now bishop cap person b7
attacking the rook here rook to a7 which
is very useful now once the bishop moves
we can put the rook on d7 go after the
queen here bishop to c6 check king to f7
this is very important also preventing
rook to d7 and now bishop to e4 offering
a trade of light square bishops we have
c4 cementing the knight on d3 and now
comes queen to f3 uh here it's uh it's
questionable whether you should
i mean what you should play but uh best
chapter e3 seems to be the way to go
attacking the rook here gaining a
valuable tempo and only after rook to d7
now we trade captures characters in
knight a4 going for this knight to b6
idea it's a very complicated position
and uh well uh who's to say what is what
here but um
it is definitely one of the
possibilities but here we have queen to
f3 now freeing up the default for the
white rooks also aligning the queen with
the king here now comes queen to f6 and
only now bishop captures and d3 we have
bishop captures attacking the rook rook
after e1 and king to g8 and here
nisipano is able in um sort of
artificially castling his king but it's
still a matter of bringing the rook into
a game you have to play h6 king
h6 king h7 move the bishop get the rook
in so quite a few moves before he
actually manages uh at the castle and he
no longer uh has an an extra pawn also
something to uh to consider uh so here
we have knight to the e4 now attacking
the queen and the just queen captures on
b2 and this piano grabs the pawn here
and how are you how are you now playing
this now again you are up a pawn
and you just give nisipano a past c pawn
so where is the compensation here knight
to g5 putting pressure on the e6 pawn
and now h6 you have to give it back in
order to
get your get your king to h7 and sort of
artificially castle knight captures on
e6 rook to f7 now going after the white
queen here and rook 8 d1 making sure
that you cannot push the pawn because
the bishop would hang
so here bishop to b4 attacking the white
rook rook to e3 and now bishop back to
e7 so still we have uh we we have to
wait before king h7 and rook comes into
the game h3 and queen to f6 now uh we
have queen to d5 beautifully played by
zavani uh going after uh the king here
putting it on on this diagonal and now
finally king to h7 we have bishop to g3
and now defending the f2 pawn also you
don't have to worry about your bishop
hanging here if the knight ever moves
and now queen to f5 offering a queen
trade but raonic says nope
rook to e5 the queens are staying on the
board queen to f6 and now rook d to e1
doubling up on the e file and now you
have to worry about a whole lot of
things like knight captures and g7 rook
captures on e7 there are so many tricky
lines here
just to give you an example in the game
rook the c8 was played which is not the
most precise way the most precise way is
rook to b8 which seems absolutely insane
because you align your rook with the
bishop on g3 they're putting it on this
diagonal the point is after knight
captures on g7 you play queen captures
on g7 and now you allow queen captures
on f7 queen captures and now rook
captures an e7 this is how you win back
the queen so rook to f8 you will not be
losing this rook rook captures rook
captures and you get this position where
white is up upon bishops are of opposite
color and it is white who is playing for
the win here
but it will it will take a lot for white
to prove that he can actually win this
however after rook the c8 which seems
like the more natural move uh you don't
put the rook on this diagonal you put
the rook behind the pass pawn you are
ready to start pushing your passport
it is much much easier for salvani to
find the winning idea and that is rook
to e3 now you are going for rook to f3
and uh how how is black to defend this
we have bishop to f5 now comes to rook
to f3 and pawn to g6 now sort of
solidifying the position but now comes
such a brilliant brilliant move by
sadwani uh you could play this is a
brute forcing idea rook captures an f5
but bishop to h4 the move that was
played in the game much more elegant
solution uh just asking what do you play
here uh the point is if the queen is
captured if queen captures bishop then
you sacrifice the knight as well knight
the g5 check and after anything captures
this now you play queen captures on f7
and after king to h8 now you trade rooks
captures captures doesn't matter where
the king goes and now you play g4 and
black resigns now the queen stuck here
can never re-enter the game the bishop
cannot move because of rook to f7
checkmate so it's a game over for black
here truly spectacular stuff so of
course uh the queen cannot capture the
bishop here so uh you you can resign
here but you could also try something
else uh in the game bishop captures any
on e6 was attempted and now trying to
trade queens but now just rook captures
on e6 and again no move here for black
uh everything is hanging here you could
go for for one check but also i mean it
doesn't really do all that much you just
play king to h2 and still yeah black's
entire position is uh
completely shattered for example if
bishop captures on h4 uh we can capture
on f7 and now checkmate the the black
king so anything is possible here so
nice pan who played queen captures on f3
he wants to win back at least some
material g captures and bishop captures
here and now it seems like you have two
rooks in the bishop against the queen
and rook but it only seems that way
queen to e4 now threatens captures and
also capture so you have to defend the
g6 spawn rook to g7 and now queen
captures on h4 so now it's two rooks
against the rook and the queen and
usually you resign here but it's the
olympiad you play for your team not for
yourself and you do have a pass pawn so
uh c3 let's push it and see maybe
something good happens with rook to e1
pawn to c2 and now queen there for
guarding the queening square rook g to
c7 hoping to promote that pawn and now
rook the c1 and here
we have rook to g7 uh point is that uh
salvani shows here how how how deep he
thought about the position if black
plays rook d7 and tries to get this rook
to d1 checking you can just play queen
e4 and now after rook to d1 check you
can play king to g2 and after rook
captures on c1 it seems like black won a
rook but now comes queen b7 check and
you will win this rook with check once
the king moves queen c3 check now you
play queen d2 kick away the rook and win
the uh the pass pawn so that's the idea
here so you can't go for this king the
g7 was played king g2 now comes pawn to
h5 and queen to d6 a very nice
centralizing move by the queen rook to
c6 we have queen e7 check king to g8 now
comes pawn to f4 preparing point five to
completely shatter
black's defenses because once f5 is
played uh you will either open up the
position either push the pawn or the
black will black will have to capture an
f5 and then you will open up the g file
for the attack and that will be it
similarly uh something happened in the
game i rocate the c7 attacks the queen
queen eight check king g7 now f5 and he
was in this position on move 57 a 47
that olivier anisi piano resigned the
game and what a spectacular victory for
ravanak sadwani in the final round of
defeat hs olympiad uh scoring a most
valuable point for team india too and it
seems like they are on their way to
winning their match but anything can
still happen as we've seen so many games
had had their ups and downs i'm not
gonna you know spoil anything or jinx
anything or you know uh
well i'm just gonna stop myself here but
basically you resign here because uh
you you don't really have a move here
after after you capture here uh we can
just play king h2 or just
or just deliver a nice check and after
the king moves i play king h2 and now we
bring a rook into the attack and that's
it whatever you play rogue g1 checking
here rook here with czech king f8 and
now you can even play rook characters on
c7 uh because uh well if you bring a
queen into the game this is checkmate so
there's that and if you capture here you
capture here the queen covers the
queening square so that's all there is
uh so yeah that's the game first game
we'll be showing from the final round
anything is still possible so i will
keep you guys informed on what what's
happening who is winning what uh but
this game by nox advanta truly truly a
masterpiece but as i always say it takes
two to create a spectacular game so hats
off to olivia the attorney spam as well
for accepting the challenge to play such
a wild game uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank michael calvert uh sonal chandra
madhukar
and kathleen althea cashman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
final round of the olympiad until it
ends so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day